the heading is oblique asymptotes and I
said I said I just happened to notice
that X minus 3 is the oblique asymptote
and in the previous one when I did we
did this one again I said I happen to
know that the oblique asymptote is X
minus 1 so how do I do that okay the
first thing I want to draw your
attention back to is that when I started
you with this guy okay I knew that it
would approach y equals x because you've
got this part here which is approaching
zero right that makes it so all you get
left with is this part okay so the short
answer to it how do you find the oblique
asymptote for something messy like that
or that is you need to get this kind of
situation you need to isolate out the
part that approaches zero and then
whatever is left will be your oblique
asymptote okay well whatever asymptote
as you'll see in a second there are
other kinds so this is what we're
working toward right so keep that in
your head
I'm trying to isolate that guy or
something that looks like it keep in
mind if it was like a two or twenty
three or 230 even though that number
looks much bigger it's still approaching
zero does that make sense
because I'm getting positive and
negative infinity on the bottom right so
no cold constant number can hold a can
of two things so it's still approaching
zero so the question is what must I do
to this thing in order to get there okay
okay so I've picked this example to do
first before we go to this guy because
it's easier because what you have on
your denominator okay
so let's expand the brackets I'm going
to get x squared negative 2 & 1 they add
to minus 1 so I have minus X in there
and then minus 2 times 1 is minus 2 so
that's my my numerator okay and all of
that is still divided by X because I
haven't done anything to the denominator
okay now because all I'm doing is
divided by X this is super easy example
okay
watch how easily this X minus 1 falls
out okay do you agree that if I've got
these three things on the numerator I
can write this one fraction sort of go
in reverse I can write as three
fractions do that I can write as X
square of X minus X on X minus 2 on X is
that Alright
one fraction I just broken it into
pieces I can just breaking into piece is
a very very useful thing all the way up
into for unit calculus and integration
stuff like that breaking up fractions
can be very useful for example because
I'm about to do this x squared + X X X
on x1 there is right there he's just
sitting there right there is the oblique
asymptote - 1 X it's gonna approach the
zero right it's gonna okay by the way
you know how we were talking about this
right how you're approaching from the
top on this side and you're approaching
on the bottom from the bottom on this
side right well whether this is a minus
or plus will tell you when you approach
from the top or one okay and in our case
we were approaching from the bottom
clips and - okay so you're positive so
that's really easy it's real easy
because the denominator is just X and
often it will be so this technique is
really great it's very fast okay but it
won't cut up when you get a guy like
that right so this is y equals again
let's expand that because we
we've got this okay so I can't just
simply breaking past and then cancel I
will do that in a second
but I need some more sophisticated tools
and the sophisticated tool that we need
it's cold polynomial division now
polynomial division I should take
polynomial long division is just like
normal long division like with numbers
okay so let me remind you because it's
been a while okay if I suppose gave you
this how would we do this seven into 300
what would I do first step yep okay
that's the second step I'd say how many
times it goes in the fifth but you of
course know it doesn't go into three so
that's why you go into 30 and the answer
is how many times four times before
there and then what do I do with that
four I multiply back by my original
divisor and that gives me 28 and then
what do I do and then I subtract now
what well well the reason why I bring
down the zero is because I ask how many
times is seven going to and the answer
is no times it doesn't go so that's why
you bring down the zero and then I say
how many times into 20 twice and now
what I do with that so what does this
six me okay so you can either say you
can either say three hundred on seven is
42 and 6/7 that's one way of saying it
or you could say and this is gonna be
more useful to us 300 divided by seven
is forty-two remainder
six is that okay or if you want to write
it the other way 300 is 7 by 42 plus six
okay and actually it's give me a very
helpful to us all right now don't freak
out right it's just algebra I'm gonna do
the same thing both polynomials instead
of numbers polynomials right so this is
yeah yeah so this is what I'm dividing
by okay just like it's 307 I'm dividing
by X plus 1 you so stick that X plus 1
at the front that's my divisor and then
what I've got over here is the thing
that I am dividing okay that's x squared
minus 2x and just for sake of it I do
need to put on the end to you that there
is zero left over okay if they always
like x squared minus two I'd have to
have zero X in there we know that
because like look these zeros here they
matter right just like the zeros here no
okay this bits a bit tricky in the
scheme of things remember this X it
could be anything it could be anything
right it could be say a million right or
it could be two okay so therefore when
I'm dividing these things right all that
really matters is the X like how many
times is the X fit into and then I go
step by step so how many times this X
fit into this guy is x times stop just
make sure you get this right don't just
machine through this mechanically what
have I done
just like that ask how many times does 7
go into 30 I'm asking how many times X
goes into x squared like how many times
does 5 go to 25 well how many times does
6 go to 36 and the answer is it goes x
times okay what do I do with this now I
think back to what we did before I take
this guy just like I took this 4 and I'm
multiplying back right I'm multiplying
it back by this whole thing which excuse
me x squared plus X you seen it x times
1 that's just X so far so good now what
do I do
I subtract so careful with your society
and I subtract so - 2 X - excuse me - 3
X ok plus a 0 double so now that I've
gone to this point I will ask the same
question my cycle begins again how many
times does X go into that it's R minus 3
times ok so then I multiply back gives
me this which means my remainder is I
take this away don't I
and it's a double negative so it's a 3
I'm subtracting negative 3
ok now coming back to this line up here
how do I write this line but this time
in polynomial form right yeah ok yeah
yeah okay so what I'm gonna start with
is what's the big number what's the
thing that I was dividing and the answer
is x squared minus 2x okay and what this
is telling me is that it's equal to this
times this
- plus sorry yeah plus that okay and we
can just check that out because I can
just expand this right what's this this
is going to be x squared plus 2x minus 3
plus 3 so these guys go and this is what
I expected
sweet it worked okay so what was the
point of doing it why is rephrasing this
so useful and the answer is so you can
do this ready watch I spent all that
time rephrasing my numerator okay so
really I know now it's this maybe the
cogs of turn you can see what this is
going to do see that just rewritten the
numerator all that long division stuff
was just so I could rewrite the
numerator but now now it's in a position
where I can break it apart see you can
break the pup I'll do it I'll do it with
all the steps there's X minus 3
and this X plus one you see
I've split it apart and now it's in a
form that can cancel and oh you get left
without the front is that X minus three
plus this guy who just disappears off to
zero as I approach positive and negative
infinity